don't you want to join me inside at the
memorial to Martin Luther King in the
nation's capital hundreds gathered for
an event President Trump says no one has
ever heard of
Juneteenth Emancipation Day the day they
were freed from slavery
a thousand miles to the west in Tulsa
Oklahoma where the president will hold a
huge weekend election rally they were
marking it - don't eat means everything
to me
June T's is a place that we as black
people can come and we could discuss and
we can share here though there is an
added poignancy for the black community
because of an event that many people
really haven't heard of the Tulsa
Massacre May 1921 and airbrushed from
the history books for many years since a
white mob swept through the black
Greenwood district burning and murdering
as they went see the building's collapse
destroy the smell of fire and smoke
still billowing in this area before the
massacre it had been known as black Wall
Street african-americans had fled
slavery in the deep south and made a
successful life here how many people
died that day at least 300 but what does
that say about about race issues in
America that people are still in denial
about such a huge event still in doubt
then now I mean that's one thing I don't
have no problem with the president
coming here it's just the attracting
that he brings he rarely dog-whistle
this base who are saying white power and
white my white lives matter and build
that wall all that raises rhetoric we
don't need that here in Tulsa we just
tried to heal the streets here reflect
the history of the place all these years
on there is still a racial divide in the
city and locals say it is so clear that
it's marked by the railway to this day
north Tulsa is the black neighborhood to
the south it's white
of course the other controversy is the
other virus Corona this is the front of
the line of what will be tens of
thousands of Donald Trump supporters
descending on a city in a state where
the curve is still upward by any measure
this is an unusual decision